[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day are you doing well
yes i'm fine good we're gonna discuss
various topics today again so i'll open
with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for giving us these opportunities
will you please bless us enlighten our
minds with the holy spirit in jesus name
amen amen
well martin i understand that
it is question time yeah
i like the questions because we get
various topics
but it also gives us some bible studies
yes we have to do some bible studies
when we
want to do these things and uh yeah
some of them are you know issues that
are
troubling to people well all of them
otherwise there wouldn't be a question
and many of the questions deal
deal with the criticism to way
to the way in which the adventists for
example interpret texts yes
and so it's it's good that we have these
opportunities so we can see what does
the bible say
yeah and it's good for everybody to
go with us through this to
see if we maybe er er um a point or so
and then you can show it us
out to us or maybe there's something you
didn't know
and we can all learn together you know
what this
this issue of studying what the bible
says
has been a bone of contention for
a very long time right eons yeah
and so nobody can say that they have
it all together nobody and everybody can
make a mistake here and a mistake there
and we have to be we have to be kind to
each other
and if there is a mistake you point it
out and you say you could have seen it
this way or that way
and yes there's room for that too
so nobody says that what we say
is the be all and end all
there are others that interpret things
differently
but to the best of our knowledge we will
try and answer it
according to the scriptures amen that's
the standard
yes so let's go on to a question
since christ entered into the holy place
before the pre-advent judgment
what was his officiating role or
ministry prior to him
entering into the holy of holies
this is a very interesting question and
it actually
the question contains more than one
would imagine at first glance right
because this whole issue where did he go
did he go into the holy
place did he go into the most holy place
that is a that is a major problem in the
world today
and why is it important to know whether
he went into the holy place or whether
he went into the most holy place and
what did he do
according to this question before
he actually entered into this ministry
correct
because the bible says that he entered
the sanctuary above not with the blood
of bulls and goats etc but with his
own blood so the actual
ministry in the sanctuary
couldn't begin until christ
had paid the price because he had to
enter with his own blood
so what did he do before that's a good
question right
well a post data check you know what a
post stated checkers modern
yes today people don't use checks
anymore in many countries
in the united states they still use
checks but in many cases
it's not no they're outdated we don't
use checks anymore
but sometimes when you wanted to pay
something but you
didn't have the actual funds you wrote
another date and you gave that to the
person and only
after that date could they actually use
the check
but they had the guarantee in their hand
correct right
yeah so the ministry of christ before
was really a post date to check
and it was by promise that he acted
out what he promised to do
in the future does that make sense yes
okay let's give a few examples
why it is absolutely essential that we
understand that christ's ministry has
never
changed it's been the same from the
beginning
the plan of salvation was laid
at the foundations right correct
let's take a few examples
was he taken to heaven yes okay
was the actual price
for enoch's sin
because all have sinned and fall short
of the glory of god
paid for at that stage no not yet no
wasn't paid for and yet he was taken to
heaven without seeing
death yes now that was
a guarantee to the anti-diluvian world
before the flood that god's promise
was actually true correct that those who
were faithful
and followed him would actually go to
heaven right
so they had a guarantee and then they
had
a prediction as to when retribution
would come
and noah preached for 120 years
and when methuselah should die then
it would come so they had the prophetic
word
they had the spirit of prophecy yes but
they also had a guarantee
that god could be trusted in terms of
his word right
so that was a post date to check
now the other example that we have is
moses moses died
and then there was an argument between
michael and the devil
over the body of moses and i can
understand why
the devil was extremely frustrated
because here moses was raised from the
dead
and he was taken to heaven and the devil
said
excuse me what right do you have to take
him to heaven
and to resurrect him and take him to
heaven what right do you have
because after all you haven't paid the
price
the price hasn't been paid he has no
right to go to heaven
and the lord didn't argue with him he
just said to him
the lord rebuked you satan and he took
him
so there's another post that's the check
so question
was his sin forgiven moses sin
yes he was declared righteous and he was
taken to heaven
yes okay who declared him righteous
jesus jesus who atoned for him
jesus but he hadn't done it yet done it
yet no
so what was it it's a post date to check
a post date to check
okay let's take another example elijah
was he taken to heaven without seeing
death yes
correct right he never saw death
he was taken to heaven was he declared
righteous yes
righteous enough to represent the living
at the end of time
that wouldn't see death so you have
moses as the example of
those that would die and be resurrected
because they had been counted worthy
blessed are those who have part in the
first resurrection
and he was taken to heaven so his sins
were atoned for
and everything that christ did
and will would do in the future in the
sanctuary
he actually did by promise before yes
so that's what he did now let's just
expand while we're at this because you
know
it's important that people understand
how this actually works
the sanctuary is actually
a model of how the plan of salvation
works now we've discussed that many
times so we're not going to go into the
sanctuary
in detail at all but that is a
mini enactment of
how the plan of salvation works
and the actual plan of salvation
the price that had to be paid the
atonement that had to take place
and the officiating work of our high
priest
actually commenced when the blood was
available
because he didn't enter with the blood
of sheep and goats
now the earthly sanctuary had
a holy place and a most holy place
and the high priest went into the holy
place
on a daily basis throughout the year but
only once a year
on the day of atonement did he go into
the
most holy place and then the record of
sin
[Music]
was removed in type and placed upon
the scapegoat the scapegoat didn't pay
for those sins
because it took blood to atone for those
sins so only the blood of christ can
atone for the sins
but eventually all the sins that have
been forgiven
that record of sin will be removed and
placed upon the scapegoat but
in other words christ is going to hold
the satan accountable
for what he incited us to do yes
and that's a very beautiful thing that's
why the scapegoat didn't die he's not a
sin
bearer for you he didn't pay any price
but he's going to have to deal with the
consequences
because you have been redeemed right
correct so on a daily basis
the priest would officiate in the holy
place
in other words every penitent sinner
that came with his offering of a lamb
would confess his sins over the lamb
and then the lamb was put to death and
that
blood was the life that flowed out
represented the lamb of god whose blood
would atone for our sins
so that life that was paid that blood
was paid because of my sin
and therefore it was recorded in
the sanctuary in the holy place onto the
horns of the altar
we could in modern terms say they were
mega hard drives
where the record of sin was stored
yeah okay and they went in to download
it onto the
they downloaded it and only when that
blood was actually
taken inside was your sin taken
inside and it had been atoned for
because there was blood
now that's a very that's a very
beautiful symbolism
atonement and the blood of christ how it
paid
for your sins but the record was there
now in in heaven one day you will be
as though you had never sinned so that
record must be removed
eventually the price has been paid so
let's just go into a little bit of
detail there because
the world would like everyone to believe
that christ entered into the most holy
at his ascension now we've dealt with
this before
but let's just go into a little bit more
detail while we have this question
okay so everything that happened before
christ was crucified was a postdated
check
by promise everything that happened
thereafter
was an actuality
the one served as a type the sanctuary
on earth
which was a type of the heavenly so says
hebrews
so that which prefigured what would
happen in heaven
was enacted in the jewish economy
that which happened because it had
become a reality
was enacted in the christian
economy does that make sense yes so the
new testament
is the expositor of the old and the two
blend together
so that we can understand now hebrews
chapter 4 says seeing then
that we have a great high priest
that is passed into the heavens jesus
the son of god
let us hold fast our profession
we have not a high priest which cannot
be touched with the feelings of our
infirmities
but was in all points tempted like as we
are yet
without sin so here is the great
antitype
jesus our high priest
and he has gone into heaven
to officiate in the sanctuary
on our behalf with the blood
now the earthly had a ministry
stretching over the year in the holy and
then going into the
most holy then the heavenly must have
the same
so we could ask ourselves why do some
people say he went into the most holy
[Music]
well that's a very interesting question
because
that would enter introduce a whole can
of worms
because we will see when we get to
daniel chapter 8 and 9 why it is
important
but if the earthly was a pattern of the
heavenly
then he would have to enter into the
holy first
so when did jesus enter the holy of
holies was it in 1844 this is another
question right
so we'll deal with them they work
together these questions
or was there a kind of sanctuary opening
before that
after the resurrection how many times
did jesus ascend to heaven so here is a
whole
host of questions in actual fact
we don't know how many times jesus
ascended into heaven
we know that he ascended into heaven
after he spoke to mary
correct right yeah i go to my father i
have not yet been to my father
i will go to my father and i will come
again
but the bible doesn't tell us what
happened in those 40 days
whether he frequently went up or not
we don't know correct correct so as for
the rest of the things let's just go
into this question of 1844. now we're
not going to deal with the prophecy but
just briefly we will say where it comes
from
in a moment daniel 8 verse 14
and he said unto me unto 2000 2300 days
then shall the sanctuary be cleansed
now this verse is the one that deals
with 1844 now if you just read daniel
chapter 8
verse 14 you don't know
where this prophecy starts
and you don't know when it ends
because in order to work it out you must
have a starting
point yes now there's no starting point
in here
so you cannot work it out from here but
in daniel chapter 9
there is a starting point
therefore you can work it out and in
daniel chapter 9
there are some major events
that are mentioned in chronological
order so that you know that you are on
the right track
all right so when does this prophecy
start and when does it end well in
daniel chapter 9 it tells you that from
the
issuing of the decree to restore and
rebuild jerusalem
unto messiah the prince
and then there's a time prophecy the
70-week prophecy
and this portion it says is cut off
from the entire time so if you have a
starting point and you take the years
it happens to work out at 1844.
there is no other date that it can work
out on
and because all the checks and balances
are there in between the messiah when he
would come
that he would die in the middle of the
week and all of these issues
verifying the prophecy that is what it
works out that
yes and we've had this discussion before
there were so many
isms that took place in 1844
evolutionism existentialism
all of these issues communism
everything started in 1844
spiritism plus
adventism all of them started in 1844
that is not
coincidental plus of course the
industrial revolution the communication
systems transport systems everything
started in 1844
in other words the message had to go out
to the entire world
so when jesus entered into the sanctuary
where did he go daniel 8
17. so he came near where i stood
and when he came i was afraid and fell
upon my face but he said unto me
understand oh son of man for at the time
of the end shall be the vision
this is very important
and then he said behold i will make thee
know what shall be in the last end
of the indignation. for at the time
appointed the end shall be
anybody who in the light of these
verses wants to cut off the old
testament from the new and say it has
nothing to do with us
has a serious problem now yes would you
agree definitely
and that's why jesus said
showing back to the prophet daniel yes
you have to have
this you have to understand this if you
don't understand this you don't know
where you are in the stream of time
and we want to deal with the stream of
time
now martin when you deal with the stream
of time
you get into trouble yes have you got
your seatbelt on
because we might get into trouble again
but we'll say it very carefully
but we'll see anyway so the prophecy
obviously the beginning of the prophecy
was from the decree when jerusalem
should be
restored that is way in old testament
times
until messiah takes us to the new
testament times
and to the very end when it when the
last indignation will take place takes
us to our time yes
so the prophecy spans the whole
period it's a very important
prophecy now let's go to daniel chapter
yay while i was speaking in prayer
because daniel couldn't understand these
things
even the man gabriel whom i had seen in
the vision at the beginning
being caused to fly swiftly touched me
about the time of the evening ablation
and he informed me and talked with me
and said oh daniel i am now come forth
to give this skill
and understanding at the beginning of
thy supplications the commandment came
forth and i am come to show thee
for thou art greatly beloved
therefore understand the matter and
consider
the vision so understand the matter and
consider the vision
if that applied to daniel do you think
it applies to us
definitely so we must understand the
matter
and consider the vision yeah that's
part of what we should do and jesus
himself
said when you see these things go look
at what daniel said right correct
so jesus wants us to understand this
and then follows the 70-week prophecy
which we've dealt with before we're not
going to deal with it but just for
completeness seventy weeks are
determined
upon thy people and upon thy holy city
to finish transgression to make an end
of sins
to make reconciliation for iniquity
and to bring in everlasting
righteousness and to seal
up the vision and prophecy and to anoint
the
most holy that's a mouthful
yeah so this concerned
the jewish era when the jewish era
would come to an end
there was a 70-week prophecy and
thereafter
would come the christian era yes right
and in this prophecy you have
words that humanity cannot fulfill
finish transgression make an end of sins
reconciliation for iniquity
bring in everlasting righteousness who
can do that
only jesus only jesus can do that so
this
takes us up to the point of jesus and
then to seal up the vision
and the prophecy which takes us to where
right to the end of time okay so this is
the ultimate span the
eons prophecy and
we should understand the matter
and consider the vision
right 100 okay
one more point over here and to anoint
the most holy
that is actually the sanctuary
so you have the sanctuary message in
here as well
and it is the anointing of the most holy
so what does the word anoint mean the
consecration
so this will take us to
the consecration of the sanctuary so
that means
to the time when jesus will enter into
that ministry yes
okay and this is important because the
word there is to anoint the most holy
and this is fascinating what an
amazing verse you know martin there are
people that say
that people with with long
scruffy hair and ugly beards
living in cavemen caveman-style
environments wrote this book
yeah there's people that say that and
the greatest geniuses of all time
have never been able to unravel it
completely right
correct if this isn't the word of god
then i don't know i've read many books
in my life
but this is the only book that you can
never exhaust
you cannot exhaust it even in a sentence
in a few words it can sometimes when you
read it again
wow i didn't see this and it blows you
away because it's in a hole
i once i once listened to a series of
lectures on one verse in daniel one
verse and it was eight one and a half
hour
lectures one verse
i and you don't even know that you can
get all of that out of it
i also i know one person that that is
doctor doctorate his thesis
on one verse absolutely colossians 2
16. well you can you can do
a thesis plus write a thousand volumes
on three words in the beginning
[Laughter]
that's a that's a major already
anyway let's go and see what happens
there
hebrews 9 12 neither by the blood of
goats and calves but by his own blood he
entered in
once into the holy place
having obtained eternal redemption
for us that's the king james version
and it says holy place and the word is
hagion
which actually means sanctuary
but he entered into the holy place
hebrews 9 12 in the niv says he did not
enter by means of the blood of goats and
cops but he entered the
most holy place once for all by his own
blood
thus obtaining eternal redemption
now which one of the two is right
we have to compare it with the rest of
the bible
not only that this one here
in my opinion is dishonest yes
because most holy place is
but this just says hagion
so is there an agenda here i believe
there is an agenda
because does it make a difference you
see
the date 1844
is an incredibly important date because
it takes us to the end of the 2300 day
prophecy and it happens to end in 1844
and after that date there will be
the cleansing of the sanctuary
cleanse it from what was the sanctuary
dirty no it only had the record of sin
it had the record of sin
and it needs to be cleansed from the
record of sin
so the cleansing of the sanctuary
fits in with the day of atonement yes
when there was this day of judgment
and the people had to repent
and think about themselves and make
right with god
because at the end when he came out the
high priest and he
placed his hands on the scapegoat if you
were not part of that process you were
cut off yes
right so that is the investigative
judgment
so when you make him enter into the most
holy place
then there is no period where you can
say okay now this day of atonement has
begun
because then we've been living in it for
the last 2000 years
right correct and that's a problem
so in other words by translating it like
this you get rid of the advent movement
yes totally the advent movement becomes
irrelevant
and the advent movement does not become
a gathering
of people out of all denominations
but just another part of the soup
so he has to get rid of the last message
of warning
and the last message of warning is the
three angels messages
by making it holy holy place by changing
it into most holy place you get rid of
the three angels messages
totally and you get rid of the call come
out of my people
you get rid of everything there is no
final message
but here's a question martin in the
anti-deluvian world
did god have a final message yes
he did yes and he gave it to noah and
how long did he preach that message
120 years 120 years
now i'm being a little bit daring here
if you if you take 120 jubilees
how many years do you get isn't it six
thousand
six thousand years that's interesting
and when you read you know in the spirit
of prophecy
you have that date mentioned many many
times
but uh we're on very troublesome ground
may i ask another naughty question
how old was moses when he was translated
120 years is that coincidental or was it
specifically planned did god say walk up
to the mountain
am i going to put you to sleep and the
bible says
his eyesight was still perfect
everything of him was still perfect it
wasn't that he was sickly
okay so now what maybe there was
something more to the hundred and twenty
all right so he suffered a death but he
also had a resurrection
okay now the resurrection isn't that a
type
of the end yes so if you had 120 years
there could you have 120 years later
now this is how some of the pioneers
used to think
and today many people believe that that
is
obsolete but i like their thinking
i like their thinking but we're on
dangerous ground so
let's just skip to another level here
but the point of the matter is is it
important
and i say yes it is exceedingly
and we've had many martin
many attacks in the world against the
advent message
and it is essential to the opponents
to have jesus enter into the most holy
place
to get rid of the relevance of the
judgment message jesus
that's it right and even within our own
ranks
there have been attacks on this and i
think of ford for example
who would make it quite a point
that he entered into the most holy and
many many a theologian will agree with
them
well it becomes troublesome if you use
the niv
because then you you can't prove
anything yeah
then you actually have a point
so there's a point here which is very
interesting
and we spoke about anoint the most holy
remember that
and the word there was the sanctuary yes
so the anointing of the tabernacle
when did that take place and what
happened there
and actually you have to go through the
whole of leviticus chapter 8.
and here's an interesting
uh statement from the signs of the times
and this statement has been used many
times
to say that jesus entered into the most
holy
when he ascended up to heaven okay
okay and ford
quoted this to say
that he went into the most holy but he
would
very cleverly leave out a little portion
so i'm not going to read his i'm going
to read it as it was
okay okay christ's glory
did not appear when he was upon this
earth
he was then a man of sorrows and
acquainted with grief
men hid their faces from him
but he was following the path god had
marked
out for him still bearing humanity
he ascended to heaven triumphant and
victorious
he has taken the blood of the atonement
into the holiest of all
that's the most holy place
sprinkled it upon the mercy seat and his
own garments and blessed the people
soon he will appear the second time to
declare that there is
no more sacrifice for sin
now martin when you read that statement
where did he go
into the most holy aha he went into the
most holy
but we've just read in the king james
that he went into the holy
now if you read the modern ones he went
into the most holy and then the judgment
message is gone
and wherever you read in the spirit of
prophecy
it says he officiated in the holy
except here he went to the
holiest of all but then you must read
very carefully
he sprinkled it upon the mercy seat
where's that
in the most in the most holy and
his own garments
now ford cleverly removed
this little section here
and his own garments
and bless the people soon he will appear
the second time to declare that there is
no more sacrifice for
sin now why is it important
that he removed and his
own garments that's
blatantly i don't want to use the word
it's a blatant falsification let's be
kind
all right why is it important okay let's
go to leviticus chapter 8.
we don't have to go through it all but
there are some salient points here
which are very interesting
and the lord spoke unto moses saying
take aaron and his sons with him
and the garments and the anointing oil
and a bullock for the sin offering
and two rams and a basket of
unleavened bread and gather thou
all the congregation together unto the
door of the tabernacle of the
congregation so now
this was a ceremony to
anoint the sanctuary
for its first use okay
and moses did as the lord commanded him
and the assembly was gathered together
unto the door of the tabernacle of the
congregation
and moses said unto the congregation
this is the thing which the lord
commanded to be done and moses
brought aaron and his sons and washed
them
with water now this is fascinating
so he took them to the lava and he
washed them with water
he washed them they couldn't wash
themselves
they were now being anointed for their
task of the priesthood
and they had to be of the descendants of
aaron yeah
and moses of course was the brother of
aaron
and moses is taking an important
position here
he's anointing aaron and his sons to the
priesthood and he washes them
what does that tell you that they
couldn't do it of themselves
they couldn't do that themselves so this
must have been quite embarrassing
here is moses and he is washing them
this tells us that christ is the one
that washes us yes all right
and he put on him the coat and girded
him with the girdle
and clothed him with the rope and put
the ephod
upon him and girded him with the curious
girdle of the ephod
and bound it unto him therewith so who
clothed them
moses yes yes he probably had his
undergarments on and the
officiating robe but this rest of the
clothing was placed upon him
by moses so in type who clothes you with
the robe of righteousness christ
and he put the breastplate upon him and
in the breastplate the urim and the
tumen
and he put the mitre upon his head
also upon the mitre even upon his
forefront did he put the golden plate
the holy crown as the lord commanded
moses so here is holiness unto the lord
so they were set apart for a holy use
they were anointed
and moses took the anointing oil and
anointed the tabernacle
and all that was therein
and sanctified them
right all that was therein does that
include the ark of the covenant
yes well if you want to make absolutely
sure just go to exodus chapter
30 where
we have a this prior description of
what happened there and we will go
to verse 26.
where this took place the ceremony and
god said to him and thou shalt anoint
the tabernacle
did we read that in daniel yes
of the congregation therewith and the
ark of the testimony
and the table and all its vessels
and the candlesticks and these vessels
and the altar of
incense now where were they in the holy
place
all right so he had to anoint the most
holy place
and he had to anoint the holy place
and the altar of burnt offering with all
his vessels and the lava and his foot
where was that outside so he had to
anoint the entire
sanctuary okay and thou shalt
sanctify them that they may be most holy
whatsoever touches them
shall be holy now martin
in all the bible when you touch
something unclean
you become unclean yes but here we have
the reverse
the holy if you touch it you're holy all
right
but nobody was allowed in there unless
they fulfilled certain conditions
or else they would die now this is
very important so we go back to
chapter 8 in leviticus we reach verse 10
again
and moses took the anointing oil and
anointed the tabernacle
and all that was therein and sanctified
them so this is a summary of what we've
just read
and he sprinkled thereof upon the altar
seven
times and anointed the altar and all
these vessels both the lava
and his foot to sanctify them so there
was a lot of activity
around the altar of burnt offering
because this typified christ and his
sacrifice
and he poured of the anointing oil upon
aaron's head
and anointed him to sanctify him
now this oil that was poured on his head
it was such a copious stream of oil
that it dripped off his beard what does
that symbolize
the holy spirit the holy spirit so god
wants to
anoint the priesthood with the holy
spirit
it's almost drenching drenching him that
the oil
dripped it was a fascinating ritual and
it
is full of symbolism and moses brought
aaron's sons and put coats upon them
so who dressed them moses moses
and girded them with girdles and put
bonnets upon them
as the lord commanded moses
and this holiness to the lord is very
essential and
it was written on the forehead what what
is there in the forehead
the seat of your consciousness okay yes
god also said he'll write this law on
the heart
and you had to put it there in your mind
it had to be in your mind you're quite
right
and he brought the bullock for the sin
offering so here in the
anointing ceremony in the
in the first ceremony that took place
before
the sanctuary could be used the whole
sanctuary had to be anointed and the
high priest had to be anointed
this is a type now if we continue and he
lays hands upon the head of the bullock
for the sin
offering and he slew it and moses took
the blood and put it upon the horns of
the altar
round about with his finger and purified
and poured the blood at the bottom of
the altar and sanctified it to make
reconciliation upon it now the ritual
with the bullock is
is very extensive there was to be a
washing as well there was
water and blood involved and when jesus
died there was
water and blood involved and it
concerned
the entire sanctuary and the people
and he took all the fat that was upon
the inwards and the coal above the liver
and the two kidneys and their fat and
moses burnt it upon the altar now the
fat stands for sin
and that will be burnt away yeah
but the bullock and his hide his flesh
and his dung he burnt with fire without
the cap
where was christ crucified without the
camp
yes and he brought the ram for the burnt
offering
and then they sacrificed the ram etc
and in verse 22 we read and he brought
the other ram the ram of consecration
and aaron and his sons laid their hands
upon the head of the ram
and he slew it and moses took up the
blood of it and put it upon the tip of
aaron's
right ear now this is all
very fascinating so firstly it was a ram
now there were two kinds of offerings
there was an offering of a lamb
and there was an offering of a ram but
here in the consecration
it was a ram now the ram represents
christ in his maturity
the lamb represents christ at the
beginning of his ministry
so christ is both he's the lamb
but he's also the ram and he paid the
price now this blood
was placed on different parts of the
body
he put it on aaron's right ear
be careful what you hear my friend and
what you listen to
and how you discern what you are
listening to
and upon the thumb of his right hand
no to this day when you go to the bank
and you register your bank account well
they use the whole hand now but in the
old days it was always the thumbprint
right
now the thumb is the one that moves your
hand
and it is basically a symbol
of how you use your hand in other words
what you do
be careful what you do
and upon the great
toe of his right foot
be careful where you walk you must walk
in the ways of the lord
you must listen to his word you must
understand his word
and you must also act
you must act accordingly
and he brought aaron's sons and moses
put the blood upon the tip of their
right ear and upon the thumb of their
right hand
and upon the great toe of their right
feet and moses sprinkled the blood
upon the altar round about so these
people were
being sanctified
absolutely sanctified there were many
rules
that were applied to the priesthood
for example they were not allowed to
drink
wine or strong drink and
very shortly thereafter nahab and
baidu they drank and they died
as a consequence yes so when the bible
says
that in the new testament times those
that follow christ will be a royal
priesthood
they must follow in the same what does
that mean
it means you must be careful with you
yeah
you must be careful what you do and you
must be careful
how you walk the christian walk right
and if you want to be part of the
priesthood
then you must abstain from
anything alcoholic right exactly okay
but uh we're still getting to the point
here we're being a little bit laborsome
here for
the people but let's try and then there
are other
issues and and offerings that they had
to do and the wave
offering etc and all of that
even the wave offering all of this
we can spend a long time because all of
this is symbolic as well
every single one christ's ministry after
his crucifixion
up in the heavenly sanctuary correct but
now we get to the crux of the matter
if you read verse 30 and moses took of
the anointing oil
and of the blood which was upon the
altar
and sprinkled it upon aaron and
upon his garments did you get that
and upon his sons and upon his sons
garments with him
and sanctified aaron and his
garments and his sons
and his sons garments
is the lord making a point there yes i
think he is
right now martin
this ritual of sprinkling the blood on
the garments
took place only once when the sanctuary
was consecrated for use
thereafter they entered into
ministry in the holy place and only
once a year did they enter into the most
holy place
now if you read this statement from the
spirit of prophecy
let's read it again christ's glory did
not appear when he was upon the earth
he came as a man of sorrows acquainted
with grief
men hid their faces from him but he was
following the path
god had mocked out for him still bearing
humanity
he ascended to heaven this is now after
the resurrection
triumphant and victorious
he has taken the blood of the atonement
into the holiest of all
sprinkled it upon the mercy seat
and his own garments and bless the
people
what and what ceremony was that
the anointing of the initiation ceremony
so when did the sanctuary
ministry begin when christ ascended to
heaven
when was the sanctuary consecrated for
use
on the same day ah so when christ
descended into heaven
the consecration ceremony took place
that is the first time that the
sanctuary may be used by the high priest
so was he in the sanctuary prior or not
no no it hadn't been consecrated here's
the consecration ceremony
and according to leviticus chapter 8 it
had to take place
before the high priest could officiate
as high priest so he consecrated the
whole tabernacle
including the most holy and then went
back into the holy
and ministered there correct and he
stayed in the holy
for a period of time until the sanctuary
had to be cleansed
cleansed from what from the record of
sin
okay now can you understand martin how
sneaky it is
to remove these words and his garments
sure yeah because then totally changes
the whole
yes then it could be anywhere at any
time then it actually means
it went into the most holy correct yeah
but this only happened at the
consecration here's another point
the accuracy of the spirit of prophecy
stuns me every time whenever this is
amazing
this is amazing isn't it now there are
people martin
that say that this person that wrote
these kinds of things
suffered under pathology of the brain
or had epileptic attacks as we said
before
and they have never ever ever
studied her over and over again except
to prove her wrong
yeah or to get rid of some
accusation which is uncomfortable
for them right and
just think how important it was that
this ceremony should take place like it
did
how humbling it must have been for aaron
and his sons yes that moses
had to consecrate them and then after
this they had to stay there
for seven days in other words they
probably had to practice
over and over and over again to make
sure they make no mistake
and they had no righteousness of them of
their own it was placed upon them
they were not washing themselves they
were washed
and their garments were sprinkled with
the blood
and this made them righteous
only through the sprinkling of the blood
can you become
righteous if this isn't the pen
of an inspired person then i've never
read
an inspired person in my life
so i hope that answers the question
whether christ went into the holy or
into the most holy
now there's also people that say but
the throne of the father is in the most
holy
so that's why he went a bit and then in
revelation it says he's before his
he went to the ancient of days so how do
we explain that part
well you see people have this idea
that god is fixed in a place
but the throne of god is mobile yes if
you
read the the vision of ezekiel for
example
you have an explanation of the mobile
throne of god
and there was more than one throne there
was a throne in the holy place as well
uh the altar of showbread was also
a throne and it has two crowns it has a
crown around it
yes two crowns two crowns because
he will sit in his father's throne
correct
they will both be part of that throne so
in the same way christ isn't pinned down
he moves but his officiation
is holy place officiation
uh you know actually this typology and
this teachings are so beautiful yes
so martin if he entered into the holy
then at some stage he must move
into the most holy if he's going to
fulfill the prefigurement in the old
testament right
he must move into the most holy at some
stage
there is no verse in the bible other
than
the prophecy of the 200 2 300 days
that gives you a cleansing of the
sanctuary period
so 1844 becomes very relevant
if 1844 becomes relevant because the
prophecy has to be fulfilled
then the judgment message the time of
his judgment has come
yes must be relevant right
now god could dispense with all of that
i mean god is all-knowing he doesn't
need books of record
he doesn't have to prove himself to
anyone
but that's not his character it's for
the others
so there are books of records so that
everybody
at the end of the entire process will be
able to satisfy themselves
that god is just and fair
and righteous and true
and just and righteous
they will say are your judgments
beautiful it's beautiful the plan of
salvation is complete
but if you ignore one little nuance
one little and his garments
you end up in total confusion and then
also
when he was in the holy place and then
in 1844 he went into the judgment
with the most holy it doesn't mean that
he doesn't fulfill
his role of the holy place anymore
otherwise there would be
no hope for anyone right he's still the
light of
the world still the bread of life yes
and he's
his righteousness still mingles with the
prayers and while probation closes you
have access to him
he's still officiates typologically for
you
at the altar of incense he's still the
light of the world he is the bread of
the presence of god
all of those things happen at the same
time
but the judgment has commenced
so martin i hope that that answers the
question
in my mind and according to the
scripture there can be no doubt
that when christ ascended into heaven
there was a consecration ceremony
where the blood was also brought into
the most holy
yes and the blood was sprinkled on his
garments
so it is the consecration ceremony yes
and thereafter christ then officiated in
the holy
until we get to the end of the 2300 day
prophecy because that's the only one
that tells me when the change took place
yes and that's 1844 yes
and daniel told us that
the prophecy takes us to the very last
events that means it must take us to the
last message of warning
yes and that is the three angels message
the three angels messages
and the three angels messages are the
equivalent of what happened
in the days of noah because he
had the type the destruction is coming
get ye into the ark so
the last generation also has the
instruction the judgment is coming the
time of your judgment
has come of the judgment has come
worship god who made the heavens the
earth
etc etc right that's the first angel's
message
and then comes the warning against
babylon and then comes the warning
against the mark of the beast which
is making void god's law and then
appeared in the book of revelation the
ark of the covenant
in heaven and you look up and you see
the ark of the covenant what was in the
ark of the covenant the law
the law so the law will again be made
prominent at the end of time
it's part of the message choose thee
this day whom you will serve
either you're serving baal and the
representative
of baal or you are serving god
either you obey god's commandments or
you obey the commandments of men
that is the issue at the end of time
right
so daniel tells us this is the final
thing
that will happen on this earth and we
are living in that time
do you think when this actually comes to
fruition and this message goes out into
the world
do you think it will be a popular
message no
no no definitely not noah's message
wasn't
popular many people must have thought
and
wondered you know when those animals
started going into the ark i mean what
was that natural phenomenon that brought
that about right
and it's interesting that
god brought the animals god brought them
because there was some
amalgamation that had taken place
so those creatures that had been
genetically
compromised were not brought into the
ark
and so here you have the same situation
we have another ark the arc is
is the final church of god where people
must be called
into its fellowship
right and associated also we have the
ark of the covenant
and everybody has to make this decision
for or against accepting
this sprinkling that we were speaking
about
so i think it's a very important issue
that we understand the sanctuary
that we understand the place of the law
and we did a whole
lecture on that just in the previous
what's up
yes so i'm amazed
sometimes martin how god
and i believe it is god is leading
in the discussions of that we are having
it's not as if we sit beforehand and
work out a list of this is what we're
going to discuss
next no we don't because now that like
this is what happens
something like a question like this gets
answered
and then it leads to something else that
god wants maybe
yes and then there's something else and
something else and i was just thinking
now
when you mention the ark of the covenant
all of this we should do a
talk on the covenants of god
the covenants of god yes because what is
the covenant
right yes are there different covenants
we'll have to talk about that yes we'll
have to talk about that because people
are confused they think that the new
covenant
makes the old covenant obsolete but as
we see the old testament
is actually the type of the new
testament right
so nothing makes anything obsolete it
just clarifies
so these are things that that really
bother people
and it's all glory like you said to god
absolutely
so let us study these things together
let's make sure
that we understand where we are in the
stream of time
because i don't know about you martin
but i am absolutely convinced
that we are in the last death throes
of this planet and the message
of warning is soon going to come to a
close
and that door will be
shut not by us but by god
and it is our prayer that everybody
will be on board this final ark
that will make its way to the sea of
glass shall we pray
please heavenly father
what a privilege to have the word
of god at our disposal
and what a privilege to know that only
god could inspire
such a message no human being
is even capable
of putting together such a plot
and then to stretch it over thousands of
years
in absolute harmony from type
to anti-type from prophetic beginning to
prophetic
end i stand astounded
and humbled at the word of god
may we all bow down to this word
and incorporate it into our lives and
into our very worship
that one day we will can we will be able
to stand
before the son of god and he can
acknowledge that we have
internalized the bread of life
this is my prayer in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you